(chill keyboard music)
(Shamali speaks in foreign language)
- [Narrator] This "Great Big Story"
is brought to you by Delta.
When we venture out into the world,
we see all that we share.
(gentle music)
Shamali Sanjaya is an avid surfer
and president of the Arugam Bay Surf Club.
- Stand up!
- On your board.
(group cheers)
(everyone laughs)
(Shamali speaks in foreign language)
(water splashes)
- [Narrator] In 2018, she formed the first
officially registered female
surf club in Sri Lanka,
but doing so wasn't easy.
Many people believed the
local women should be at home,
not on the water.
(Shamali speaks in foreign language)
(group cheers)
(gentle music)
(Shamali speaks in foreign language)
(upbeat music)
(light chime music)